le chocolat on n'y résiste pas avec
special k chocolat au petit déjeuner
vous pouvez succombé aux plaisirs de
vrais copeaux de chocolat sans les mots
crève
le magazine québécois de la consommation
protégez-vous vient de révéler les
résultats de ces tests ce mois ci sur
plus de 330 serial disponible en magasin
or trois serial sur quatre échouent aux
tests de qualité à peine 84 des 332
serial évalué pour édition de son
magazine de février 2010 est son digne
de figurer sur la liste d'épicerie des
canadiens depuis deux ans audrée
parentaux et chef de pupitre au magazine
protégez-vous où les magasins d'aliments
naturels
on s'est basé sur trois critères donc on
cherchait des eriad on est peut-être
celle est qui sont essentiels pour faire
des produits qu'on avait analysé t
recommandé cette année pour des critères
équivalent c'est seulement 25% des
productions recommandé sylvain
charlebois et spécialiste en politique
agroalimentaire à l'université guelph
dans la province de l'ontario soffrina
une grotte steria la voix de jours
n'était pas la mode de nos jours et
depuis quelques années on voit là que
les consommateurs boudent de plus en
plus les produits à base de céréales au
petit déjeuner si nous c'est rien ne
sont plus perçus comme produits santé
par nombre de consommateurs canadiens
cela pourrait se traduire par une
accélération déclin de l'emprise de l'
empire du grain sur nos estomacs le
matin les canadiens consomment déjà
l'équivalent d'une pleine boîte de
céréales de moins qu'au milieu des
années 2000 et ce chaque mois des
résultats de l'enquète de protégez-vous
n'ont rien ici pour freiner ce déclin
les producteurs de grains qui injecte
plus de 20,1 milliards de dollars par
année par l'économie québécoise devrait
jouer un rôle plus important en
alimentation humaine
ce qu'il est question de la qualité des
aliments ils sont bien d'accord avec
cette hypothèse de travail a toujours
bien conduit le quelles sont les
attentes les besoins des consommateurs
on a quand même une production québec
que pk mably bergie et si on vers big et
président des producteurs de grains du
quai d'accueil on voit la production de
grains conventionnelle jusqu'à la
production de lire un billet d'avion en
corse en par un ensemble de production
où l on retrouve le caractère vicieux
sont attendus par un oubliez donc dans
un premier temps ils veulent s'assurer
le gain produits de première qualité
évidemment pas qu'on fait après un
complexe mondial qu'est ce qu'il
recherchait dans un premier temps c'est
de retrouver un équilibre où on peut
s'assurer de demeurer compétitive il
existe une boîte ni dans le monde entier
et ce qu'il y a dans ses posts change
pour le meilleur
la nouvelle recette des céréales spécial
k c'est une explosion de saveurs la
sélection unique de trois céréales pour
plus de goût et plus de nutrition
désormais avec des céréales complètes et
des fibres dans chaque bol
quand vous verrez cette boîte vous serez
que ce qui est bon à l'intérieur
et pau à l'extérieur
consommateurs devraient l'être au pays
un acteur incontournable de l'industrie
alimentaire
d'ailleurs à plusieurs égards notamment
dans le secteur des produits bio
il est depuis quelques années mais
beaucoup de ménages reste à faire le
prêt-à-manger des clients pour le prêter
francine rodier et spécialiste en
marketing à l'école des sciences et de
la gestion à l'université du québec à
montréal
il va y avoir des enjeux au niveau des
consommateurs par rapport à l'or leur
quête d'être chaude en parle de la santé
montre le plus ciblé de quête de
protéines alors on veut dire tiens c'est
également en vo c'est traiter davantage
qu'on achète l'information est de plus
en plus accessible et gens sont plus
sensibilisés ou qu'elle allie donc on ne
regardait plus d'où viennent les
aliments en termes de local équitable
biologique et on revoit savoir surtout
les générations je dirais plus jeunes
veulent savoir davantage d'où viennent
leurs choses iraient en général ils y
vont tenter de répondre que le client
demande donc il ya beaucoup de pouvoir
ce consommateur le il est très
intelligent très est de plus en plus
informés alors à ce moment là un bon
étiquetage des produits voir tout le
long de la chaîne de production
un virage santé vers un produit de
céréales de qualité pourrait devenir à
moyen terme une affaire de survie pour
toute cette industrie
les canadiens votent avec leur cuiller
leur bol et leur poids non le matin à
l'heure actuelle cependant ils ont de
bonnes raisons de s'abstenir de voter
évaluer les tripes nutritionnelle de ses
produits leur en fait retrouvé des
céréales qui était pas trop sucré trop
salé est riche en fibres qu'être une
crypte aux journalistes aux responsables
du contenu santé et alimentation au
magazine québécois
protégez vous avec comme résultat que 75
% des produits ne parle pas le taire
dans certains cas on trouve près de la
moitié du poids de la céréales en sucres
si on prend par exemple les délits
surpris au miel de salive céréales elles
ont 30 g de sucre pour une portion de 55
g la même chose pour les choque plus que
les enfants aiment souvent ils
contiennent 29 grammes de sucre la
portion de 55 g
c'est plus que dope de ce que nous
avions fixé le com comme limite à 12 g
par portion le pour nos bons choix et
pour nos meilleurs choix c'était
agréable donc on est loin du compte avec
eux les céréales et hichri un reportage
de radio canada international